hello everyone um i'm just catching my
breath um from this amazing day that
we've had today um so please forgive me
if i fumble or stumble or i get things
wrong
i'm just so full of excitement
of what we've kind of achieved today and
of what's about to come so
a massive massive hello and welcome to
the edinburgh tv festival and a huge
and welcome back to the city ignore all
the dustbins pretend they're not there
ignore all the rubbish just welcome back
to this beautiful city
um i hope that you are all going to make
the most of the next four days to
reconnect with people i have had so many
conversations and encounters with people
that i haven't seen in the flesh for the
last couple of years and they have been
so full of joy and warmth and they've
been incredibly heartwarmed and i want
you all to hopefully feel exactly the
same it's so brilliant to be part of
this industry and it is a privilege to
kind of work in this industry as well
so
let's think about this um as
conversations with friends but without
the slow bits how lucky are we
to work in such a creative environment
as they almost always say on gogglebox
it's been a year of great telly um we've
met new friends like julia annika we've
met the outlaws hunted nathan and james
pam and tommy and surang jones as a
human torpedo
we've watched anton deck and panorama
kick the ground from under a prime
minister and we've marveled at help the
dropout sherwood big zoo and his two
baftas and the puppet master
we've said farewell to old friends eve
and villanelle saul goodman the derry
girls and the shelbys
i asked myself just how much more
amazing drama can come out of south
korea
attorney wu
i'm talking about you
how great has it been to watch mo and aj
transform the way we start our weekends
with the new big breakfast with such an
inclusive cast and crew
but my favorite moments of this year has
been watching ms marvel and its muslim
teenage superhero kamala khan
there must absolutely
be a part for a big sister in series two
i will absolutely make my own costumes
for that
um i am so so looking forward to house
of the dragon i've not watched it yet
but i am fizzing with anticipation to
watch this um along with gladiators and
it seems like every other returning show
from my youth um
tv's in an endless
kind of creative cycle at the moment and
who knows maybe next year we might even
get a game show out of squid game
so now i'd like to introduce our player
number one aqua hirsch
this year's advisory at edinburgh's
advisory chair
as an author a filmmaker journalist and
barrister afword brings a huge amount of
experience and expertise and a different
perspective even if she isn't
appreciated by everyone in government
and after some words from her our
brilliant mctaggart speaker emily
maitlis lately of the bbc and now global
she has an electrifying take on a
challenge facing all broadcasters and
journalists impartiality in the age of
populism
before that though guys a massive thank
you to campbell gleny
and stuart clark
and then
[Applause]
and all of their amazing teams
in front of screen behind screen who
have made this happen this year
and finally my last shout out to our
guests from the festival's new entrance
scheme the network the emerging leaders
wait wait your time is coming um the
ones to watch and tomorrow's academic
experts on tv's phd
and
not just from this year but from 2020
and 21.
these were the years
these are the years that we couldn't all
be together so having us all in one room
is remarkable so there's 200 of you i'm
going to hand over now to our thank you
so much
[Applause]
good evening everyone
i have experienced tv from so many
perspectives like
most of you all of you i imagine first
as a viewer and i don't think i can
express enough for all of us how much tv
has shaped
my identity my cultural experience my
emotional relationship
with myself as a black british woman how
i feel about my culture my britishness
my values my tastes my perceptions of
the world that we live in
those influences have been nuanced
positive and negative
and over the years i have found a voice
with which to respond and critique to
the huge and profound influence that
this median has had over me and millions
of others as my career evolved i became
a contributor then a presenter and now
as fatima said a writer a producer and
someone with a platform and power myself
it is a huge responsibility
and one i take so seriously
and i'm grateful for that responsibility
and determined to use it wherever i can
for good
for many years now i have been
developing a narrative of what i think
our problems are as a society but
importantly here as an industry
we have no room whatsoever for
complacency there are so many challenges
we are yet to deal with some we're only
just beginning to even evolve a language
for
my decision to accept the opportunity to
be advisory chair and help shape the
creative content of the festival this
year was really
one of my efforts at having critique the
problem so much
offering i hope part of the solution and
i do that as well with extreme gratitude
to fatima who is an incredible chair of
the edinburgh festival i just like to
give an extra round of applause to
fatima
somebody who has hugely encouraged and
supported and inspired me in my journey
in tv and also to the entire team at
this festival who are mainly unseen to
you all but work incredibly hard over
august when everyone else is on holiday
they
do an incredible job not least of
extracting unpaid work from lots of very
talented people in tv because this is a
charity and as fatima said and as you
all know the work that this festival
does
to create new opportunities for a new
generation is also equally important
so our speaker tonight
is somebody who has stood out to me for
most of this time for a number of
reasons
first as an example of excellence in her
role as a journalist
presenter
interviewer
and
a voice throughout some of the most
turbulent and challenging times
in our current affairs cycle ever
she is an example of a woman who has
been unstoppable on a mission to hold
those
in power to account the reason that so
many of us became journalists
in the first place and also as a
multi-talented and kind human being
who i have had the pleasure to work with
on occasion and whose programs and
importantly also whose book
have
made a real difference in opening space
for honest conversations and revealing
what it is like to occupy the position
she does
it's a special privilege to be here in
person tonight it's actually my first
ever edinburgh tv festival in person
i've only been coming to the festival
for the last two years and those were
all virtual events the energy and the
passion for this conversation here has
been undeniable and it's really
wonderful to be part of it and the
message that i have received loud and
clear from all the events that i've been
to so far all the breakout conversations
even
chats in the loo
have been
how desperate you all are for honesty
for truth
and for those who do have power in this
industry to stand up to the principles
that i know
we all share
and
even
when that manifests as tough love
and a demand that we need to do better
and it's in that spirit that i'm
absolutely delighted to welcome to the
stage to give our mctaggart lecture for
2022 emily maitlis
[Applause]
thank you
i just
i just want to take you back
it's november the 9th
2016.
a lucky few of us are crammed into a
hotel room in washington it's doubling
as our news night office
and it's around
9 00 a.m
we've worked through the night an
election show which ended a bit later
than usual in times square new york
followed by a mad dash headlong into the
dawn rush hour of that traffic clogged
dc i am unslept bewildered frizzy-haired
badly in need of a bath
and donald trump has just won the
presidential election
london
is by now fully awake they've got five
hours on us and for my editor ian katz
comes an exhortation i will never forget
do not
normalize this moment
he says
and that's perhaps where it all began
ladies and gentlemen it is a huge honor
to be here tonight thank you for bearing
with the drop intro you'll have to
forgive me i'm a pent-up broadcaster and
i haven't been on air for five months
so
i said it's an honor
but it is also a responsibility
as afa was saying it's a responsibility
to get it right
and what i'm hoping to share with you
this evening
is the result of thoughts that have
honestly been accumulating in my brain
for years certainly pre-november 2016
accumulated conversations with
colleagues arguments with friends bit of
running commentary along the thames
towpath and the excellent work of so
many peers and academics
and i have been incredibly lucky in my
career to have i guess had that chance
to hold power to account princes yes
prime ministers presidents
policymakers but here's the thing
it
it is
it's got and it is getting
harder
and tonight i want to just explore that
because my suspicion
oh no okay be braver my thesis is that
the political actors have changed
politics has changed but we as
journalists
have not yet caught up
but back to that dc hotel room anyway
it's a close-up on the illegible scroll
this dog-eared notebook this is me
grappling now with my
news night introduction for that night
and my editor's words still ringing in
my ears now he's not doubting the result
or the democratic mandate but he's
insistent that we shouldn't move on too
quickly we should stay as it were in the
[ __ ] me moment
and so i start to spell out what i'm
trying to say and i'm sort of scrawling
and thinking and i'm getting my
introduction together and i say
to the names of jefferson madison
washington adams we can now add trump
taste it
roll it around your tongue america's
president-elect is donald j
trump
but washington is this extraordinary
place it is a well-oiled machine that
uses power as its fuel and within 12
hours of that shape-shifting election it
was doing what it did best it was
carrying on the wheels of government
start back up
barack obama invites donald trump to the
white house michelle obama reaches out
to melania trump
and we watch the mechanics of that
transfer of power the 44th president
welcoming in the 45th president as if
this slick political show could simply
replace one protagonist with another
we did not yet understand that it wasn't
replacing one man with another
but one set of rules with another
we didn't realize
we would have to change too
and that's what i'm here to explore
so
first up i hope i won't disappoint when
i say this is not actually a post bbc ex
employee rant i've had
seriously two decades of opportunity
that could not be bettered i owe my
success and more importantly my
happiness to the friends the soul mates
the work environment i had there and all
the endless talking we did
but this is in a sense
an exhalation
a deep
breath out
all the things that wisely could not be
said then can be said more easily now
so i'm going to try and do that
and whilst this is a lecture
it's not meant to be a lecture i mean i
must salute the incredible journalists
who've been on this from the beginning
unafraid and undaunted you know who you
are
now this is
this is more of a way of owning my
mistakes by sharing them hopefully
speaking to a generation of newcomers to
journalism who won't then make them and
i've called this lecture
boiling frog why we have to stop
normalizing the absurd
because my contention is
that despite ian's laudable
protestations all those years ago
we're becoming anesthetized to the
rising temperature in which facts get
lost constitutional norms trashed claims
frequently unchallenged
this surreal summer has been a prime
example
a total disconnect between the dire
warnings over energy and food bills that
are massively hurting people in this
country and the sw1 power vacuum circus
we followed tory leaders on tour
assessing their views on the culture
wall the price of their accessories or a
tax cut we've heard not once but twice
from the front runner that a policy idea
was misinterpreted by the media and that
my favorite a question was asked in a
left-wing way
we then saw that same candidate caught
privately apologizing to the presenter
for attacking the media as if it had
been an indelicate comment she'd made
about his tie rather than a staple of
our democracy
and we only know that conversation
because it was caught on hot mic
that conversation should have been said
out loud
this isn't normal
or rather
it shouldn't be
things that for many decades were givens
the checks and balances on the executive
the role of the judiciary or the civil
service or the electoral commission a
media free from interference or
vilification now appear vulnerable we're
seeing politicians move in directions
that are deeply and clearly deleterious
to basic democratic government
so what has changed
well there's always been scope for abuse
in our constitution of course but in
recent times
so many previously settled questions
around our democratic norms have been
upended and at a staggering speed
dr hannah white of the institute of
government observes this is not about
introducing change per se which we've
always seen it's about people in power
who are prepared to test the very limits
of the constitution to achieve their
aims
you don't have to look far for examples
things that once would have shocked us
now seem commonplace the ministerial
code violated with impunity a blatant
disregard for the principles of the
cabinet manual the unlawful attempt to
prerogue parliament for five weeks by an
executive that wanted to remove
parliamentary democracy from the
decision-making process
the blink and you miss it moment the
governing party's twitter account
changed its name to fact check uk
in the middle of an election campaign to
cope party propaganda in a format that
sounded objective
or the admission by the then northern
ireland secretary that he'd be prepared
to break international law but only in a
very specific and limited way
like murder i'm not sure the breaky of
international law gets off the hook for
being limited and specific
we can go on limits placed on judicial
review ministers failure to defend the
role of the judiciary efforts to
increase political control over public
appointments the attempts made to change
parliamentary conduct rules for cronies
you know all this you can join in the
chorus on the other side of the world
the former australian pm scott morrison
was discovered to have awarded himself
the powers of five additional
ministerial authorities this autocratic
indulgence signed off by the governor
general kept secret from cabinet
colleagues from his parliament and from
the australian people
not so secretly donald trump
unilaterally declared himself the winner
of an election he lost
this is just the context dr white
believes the key dynamic here has been
about privileging alternative sources of
authority the will of the people in the
referendum johnson's personal mandate to
try and stay in power the shutting out
of ethics advisors or the lord's
appointment commission when taking
decisions
david alan greene the law and policy
blogger points to a failure of two what
he calls safety mechanisms the first
being self-restraint of the executive
the second being the gatekeepers of
cabinet and the cabinet office who are
meant to step in when all else fails
well the long-term effect of those
trends i'm going to leave to others
but what i want to look at today
is where we come in
journalists broadcasters specifically
the impact that populist rhetoric is
having on the way we do our job
social media creates an arena that is
exceptionally favorable to the language
of populism because it benefits
simplistic emotional messages that suits
the elevate the elevation of grievance
and ours is an industry that rewards
speed amplification and the intimacy of
the anonymous off-record briefing
many studies have looked at the impact
that the media has had on helping
populists to power
but i now want to ask the opposite
question what effect does ruling
populism have on how we work one person
who studied this intensively is the
gates cambridge scholar ayala panievsky
she's looked at the way that populist
rhetoric has been used to discredit and
to disempower journalists we got used to
that enemies of the people vitriol at
the height of the maga days but then
came more subtle ways doxing of
journalists cyber bullying the tweeting
out of private journalistic inquiries to
encourage a public pile on she notes
that even the right of reply can and
frequently is used as a way of their
marrying claims that are meant to put
journalists in their place as they know
that a fair and balanced media will feel
compelled to cover them
but
and i think this is where it gets
interesting apart from these methods of
incitement of the public there's also
she says
the impact on journalists themselves
this is her the way populist rhetoric is
used to discredit journalists turns into
a sophisticated form of soft
censorship
and she uses a term that i hadn't come
across before strategic bias to explain
the way we may be inclined to respond to
accusations made against us
unlike other targets of populist
criticism journalists find themselves
required to mediate we have to mediate
that criticism to the public so we are
then put in a particularly awkward
position
and the outcome she writes is ironic
that journalists under attack
end up practicing bias in order to
signal their balance and impartiality it
is she believes
a coping mechanism we do it to ourselves
now populism make no mistake is not a
traditional ism of ideology it's not
marxism or reaganism it has
no adherence to a set belief or policy
the political scientist kashmir explains
it as the idea that society is separated
into two groups at odds with one another
the pure people and the corrupt elite
the editor-in-chief of foreign policy
moises naim goes a step further he says
populism is best understood as a
strategy for gaining and wielding power
frequently it's a method of campaigning
often in the guise of the underdog and
once in power in government it continues
to campaign picking imaginary fights to
assert its struggle even though it is
now demonstrably
undeniably
the top dog not the underdog
so what follows here just to be clear is
not a critique of left or right
conservatives versus rate labor democrat
versus republican
none of this has anything to do with
policy
it's why populist parties can shape
shift between the right and left attract
voters of traditional parties or non
it's not an ideology it is a means to
achieve and retain power
and i speak from experience when i say
that it took us too long to recognize it
for what it was
and to find the journalistic tools
needed to deal with it
i remember to my shame
interviewing the trump acolyte sebastian
gorka on news night in the early days of
the trump victory
goku would use up most of the interview
time by screaming abuse at the bbc
now he didn't have any problem with the
bbc he quite liked the bbc and he was
always happy to say yes to the interview
but he used our time on air
and that of many of my colleagues as an
effective conduit to sell a key populist
message
that the mainstream media could be
dismissed as fake now once you
understand how this works it seems so
obvious you kick down belief in a
trusted source of news you make the
audience doubt what they're seeing and
you step into the breach a shameless
play for power and dominance
but in those days i didn't
and as a journalist i was mortified
and i would spend half of our allotted
interview time trying to defend our
objectivity and the rest
bending over backwards to reconcile his
strangled version of the truth just to
prove his criticism of me wrong
in so doing ironically i lost the very
objectivity i was seeking to defend
when i was writing this i actually
looked back at an interview i did with
him in 2018 to see if ayala paniyevsky's
words rang true i think he won't be me
i'll be fine i was horrified
my opening question to him i said this
dr gorka i know in our previous
encounters we have spent a lot of time
analyzing whether news night itself is
fake news so just for the sake of our
viewers and moving the story on why
don't we agree to recognize that's how
you view things
it is insane
we didn't spend a lot of time analyzing
he leveled the accusation to get social
media traction and i allowed it to
become viable debate you see where i'm
going with this either way gawker one
and the bbc lost
this is when donald trump was already
finding his feet as president
but our mistakes started long before
that
i'm going to take you this time
to early 2016
the uk is beginning to debate the big
questions around britain's potential
exit from the eu
it's complicated stuff we're trying to
offer our viewers both sides of a
fiendishly difficult debate
and that intention was right
but we still got it wrong
we fell into what we might call the
patrick minford paradigm
in other words it might take our
producers five minutes to find 60
economists who feared brexit and five
hours to find a sole economic voice who
espoused it but by the time we went on
air
we simply had one of each we presented
this unequal effort to our audience as
if it was balance
it wasn't
i'd later learn that the ungainly name
for this myopic style of journalism was
both sideism which talks to the way it
reaches a a superficial balance whilst
obscuring a deeper truth
this stage i'd never heard the term or
indeed the criticism i just thought we
were doing our job
one year after the brexit vote shortly
after the 2017 election had left prime
minister may without a majority and in a
particularly precarious position i
remember interviewing the prominent
leave campaigner also a former candidate
for prime minister andrea ledson
the eu council president had told the
bbc of his concerns over brexit
relations
and when i asked ms ledsim what she
could point to that wasn't was going
well in the negotiations
she told me with some exasperation
it would be helpful if broadcasters were
willing to be a bit patriotic the
country took a decision
now look you could argue that my
patriotism at that moment was shown in
an attempt to do the job well interpret
for our licence fee paying public the
state of government negotiations
but i do think that's missing the point
it's certainly missing the strategy
because the way populism works on us as
journalists
is to somehow seek to divide us from the
public to make us feel that we are not
of the people that those in power are
the only ones that can understand
normal folk and that we the media are
somehow getting in the way of that
relationship between the people and
their government
back to paniyevsky who writes this
failure is framed as the media's grand
conspiracy against the populist as the
representative of the people
i wonder if you remember donald trump's
admission to
the cbs correspondent leslie stahl on
the campaign trail
she would later tell an awards dinner at
the moment that he admitted the real
reason for his continually bashing the
press i'm quoting ms stahl here she said
he said you know why i do it
i do it to discredit you all and demean
you all so when you write negative
stories about me
no one will believe you
the larger the gap in other words that
populists can create between
recognizable media sources and the
people the less impeded they will be by
any scrutiny any attempt to hold them
accountable for the decisions they make
in power
you think that's old news
just last week liz trust told the host
of the gb news hustings it's not the bbc
here you actually get your facts right
it was an artful bit of flattery which
she used to evade a challenging question
now in the earlier led some example her
rebuke to my patriotism which if we're
being generous might have been
completely unconscious
could be viewed as a way of stopping me
being the conduit the challenger between
government negotiations and the public
audience and casting me
in the role of the outsider the traitor
someone who didn't quite care enough
when he was leader of the labour party
jeremy corbyn could also be dismissive
of what he would call as trump had done
the mainstream media
his supporters would argue i think it
was not without good reason
certainly undeniably the murdoch
rothermere owned papers made no secret
of their contempt for the man who wanted
to be the next labour prime minister
their attacks on corbyn were relentless
and vicious
but his distaste for a large proportion
of the broadcast media
amplified by a small but dangerous group
of hardened fans would see the bbc's
political editor have to attend the
annual labour party conference
accompanied by a bodyguard for her own
safety
laura koonsberg's press conference
questions and that of several of her
colleagues were met with boos
it speaks volumes that the editor
remained irreproachable against an
atmosphere of such hostility
our own news night encounter of this
kind was minor in comparison
but it is probably worth putting on
record here
in march 2018 after the salisbury
poisoning of the scripples
the then labour leader jeremy corbyn
told parliament that he found the act
appalling but he angered mps by refusing
to directly condemn moscow putin over
its alleged responsibility for the
poisoning it involved the military-grade
nerve agent novichok after all
so it was a story that we decided we put
on news night that night with a large
screen large plasma screen of the
kremlin to symbolize the russia context
and jeremy corbyn in the forefront as
the subject of that piece
that night
twitter was a light
with corbyn supporters alleging our
graphics team had doctored the image to
make jeremy corbyn
appear more russian
the canary website accused newsnite of
creating
a blatant visual association between
vladimir putin's red russia and corbyn's
red labor
a squawk box blog stated that the hat in
the news night composite has clearly
been enlarged upwards for effect and
corbin's coat darkened so he looks more
like a russian politburo member
newsnight's program editor jess brammer
tweeted out a replica of that same
screen we'd used a month earlier this
time with the then defense secretary
gavin williamson in the foreground
curiously it was channel 4
who went to the effort of a full fact
check on that
they found that the hat only appeared
taller because of a perspective
distortion that was caused by the
curvature of the screen newsnight's
background screen
in other words our graphic designer had
received a vicious social media pylon by
people attributing to the program a
malice or a bias that could easily be
traced to the shape of a tv studio
plasma
honestly at that time we weren't sure
whether to find the episode farcical or
threatening
but we certainly felt very alone and
rather caught in the headlights
but looking back now in this context
i understand what ms paniyevsky means
when she talks about journalists
strategic bias
because by the end of that week
we had invited on a corbyn supporter
commentator to explain to us what we had
done wrong
and she explains that the broadcaster's
desire to be seen as neutral agents
paradoxically enables populists to
further spread the claim that we are not
we were offering a platform to the very
people
trying to tell the public to distrust
our news
sometimes we tie ourselves in knots over
the both sides and balance i spoke of
before
my editor dan clark reminded me of the
time we were granted an interview with
robert de niro from new york
it was the height of covert
and new york had been decimated by the
disease there were makeshift morgues and
a ghostly city abandoned by anyone with
the means to leave it was a really
sobering
time but equally an exciting one to have
an interview with one of the world's
best loved actors
and i just wanted to know what it felt
like for this archetypal new yorker to
see the city and its people so bereft
as we began the interview however it was
clear that de niro had other things on
his mind than new york
he wanted to rage about president
trump's mishandling of the pandemic he
accused him of not caring how many died
it was
for context
three weeks after trump had given the
infamous bleach press conference
where he was seen to be suggesting the
use of disinfectant to fight covid
inside the body
de niro told me i'm going to spare you
my de niro voice because i don't think
you want that here
it's great
daenery told me it's scary because
everyone is sort of non-plussed and
stunned at what this guy trump is doing
you've got a lunatic saying things that
people are trying to dance around it's
appalling
but in my ear dan editor dan is urging
me as is his editorial job to put the
other side
and i'm
resisting it because quite frankly
what is the other side
do i say nonsense bleach might work we
just won't know until we've tried
what i mean or do i pretend you didn't
mention the disinfectant oh no i don't
think we've heard that no it's on the
tape
or do i say
oh you're only saying that because
you're a liberal lefty lovey democrat
which
doesn't seem to capture the gravitas of
this moment when he's talking about a
horrendous death toll in america
so as an attempt at pushback i begin
trump's fan base would take issue with
that
well they would of course that's why
they're his fan base right
but de niro then bats this away by
saying
trump doesn't care for these people the
people he pretends to care about the
people he has the most disdainful
which i let hang in the air
because quite frankly
i've heard many within trump's own party
and trump's own circle say the exact
same thing to me
anyway the reason i'm recounting this is
not for the exchange but for what
happens next
we finish the pre-recorded interview
adam kamsky is the output editor he's a
big film buff and as we're heading up in
the lift i turn to adam and i say we
can't possibly run this
it's to anti-trump
and adam looks at me to see if i'm
joking and i'm not i'm terrified that by
putting out the interview as it stands
we will be seen as biased
de niro is a world famous actor and a
new yorker and he's chosen our program
news night as the place to land his
thoughts quite carefully
so why do i feel unable to let him say
it without trying to find an equally
world famous actor who that same night
is miraculously going to tell us the
opposite
and wouldn't i be tumbling into both
scientism false equivalence even if we
had
it speaks again to how forcefully even
these imagined populist accusations of
bias work on the journalists brain to
the point where we censor our own
interviews to avoid the
backlash
the coder to this story is that the de
niro interview did go out probably with
more but his fan base pushed back from
me than was strictly necessary and the
sky didn't fall down adam at least was
very happy the newslines were picked up
around the world
but it's curious now to look back on our
reactions because of what happened two
weeks later
the now infamous dominic cummings news
night introduction got way more
attention than in truth
it ever deserved
it was neither
the best nor the worst opening we've
ever done
i say we because the scripts were as
always written modified rewritten edited
signed off by a team
the original story you'll remember had
been broken by pippa cruz her excellent
colleagues at the mirror who then went
on to report many more stories
of rule breaking over the subsequent 12
months we merely picked up the story the
day after the cummings rose garden press
conference
and our intro stated bluntly and boldly
that he'd broken the rules
and it asked why the government boris
johnson was standing by him
the introduction set out as is often the
case the rest of the show
we had conservative mps explaining the
pm's loyalty we had pollsters explaining
the public horror on that issue we had
defenders we had critics and we had a
detailed analysis of which rules had
been broken and when
in other words the introduction was
appraisee of what viewers could expect
of the whole show
and on the night itself the programme
passed off with
a few pleasant texts from bbc editors
and frankly little else
it was only the next morning
that the wheels fell off
a phone call of complaint was made from
downing street to the bbc news
management
this for context is not unusual it
wasn't unusual in the blair days far
from it in the brown days in the cameron
days what i'm saying is it is pretty
normal for government spin doctors to
vocalize their displeasure with
journalists
what was not foreseen was the speed with
which the bbc sought to pacify the
complainant
within hours a very public apology was
made
the program was accused of a failure of
impartiality the recording disappeared
from the iplayer and there were
paparazzi outside my front door
now don't get me wrong i'm not standing
here trying to pretend our intro was the
gettysburg address
when i hear it now
honestly i think it was a bit
long-winded wordy sounded a bit peaked
but i don't think wow what a shocking
breach of impartiality because we called
out the actions of one of the chief
architects of the coveted laws
we show our impartiality when we report
without fear or favor
when we're not scared to hold power to
account even when it feels uncomfortable
to do so when we understand that if
we've covered rule breaking by a
scottish chief medical officer or an
english government scientist then
journalistic rigor should be applied to
those who make policy within number ten
the one person ironically who understood
this
was dominic cummings himself who texted
me that very evening to offer his roy
support
so back to the speed of response weird
right
why had the bbc immediately and publicly
sought to confirm the government
spokesman's opinion
without any kind of due process
it makes no sense for an organization
that is admirably famously rigorous
about procedure
unless it was perhaps sending a message
of reassurance directly to the
government itself
put this in the context
of the bbc board
where another active agent of the
conservative party a former downing
street spin doctor and former advisor
to bbc rival gb news now sits
acting as the arbiter of bbc
impartiality
according to the financial times he's
attempted to block the appointment of
journalists he considers damaging to
government relations
provoking labour's deputy leader among
others to call it tory cronyism at the
heart of the bbc
the uk correspondent of the german
public broadcaster ard and at dither
goes a step further
she writes public service broadcasters
must always act as the corrective
should always hold governments
accountable must never end up becoming
the megaphone that's the whole point of
publicly owned broadcasters in a liberal
democracy
and panievsky
has a warning for what happens when we
avoid rebuffing populist accusations
she believes that journalists become
complicit in the debilitation of their
own status and authority
paradoxically she writes their attempts
to protect their professional objective
facade may contribute to the public's
belief they are in fact
biased
we're doing it to ourselves
we
journalists management teams
organizations are primed to back down
even apologize to prove how
journalistically fair we are being
and that can then be exploited by those
crying bias
if it suits those in power to shut us up
or down
they can
critically
it is lose-lose for the audience
and there's the rob
because whatever our journalism does it
must earn the trust of our listeners our
audiences our readers otherwise
we are mouthpieces we are mere clients
of those in authority
cozy with those in command disconnected
from the very people that we are trying
to serve
a lot of the examples that i've used
here have been from my own experience
they weren't meant to be my greatest
hits nor my walk of shame it's just the
stuff that i found easiest to revisit
with questions of how
we should be doing our job better
i apologize to anyone who came thinking
this would be about the prince andrew
interview
that we'll have to wait till next time
promise
and to those of you
wondering why this still feels stuck in
the brexit and the trump days i'll say
this
we are
those two seismic shifts have not
been and gone they've come and stayed
18 months after an attempted coup on the
capital on the democratic functioning of
america the architect behind the lie
that brought the rioters is considering
another run for president with the
backing of millions of americans
here in the uk we spent early summer
watching the havoc at dover customs meet
with a wall of silence around brexit
those who promise to get brexit done
can't mention it because it clearly
isn't
their insistence on third nation status
has meant passport checks and horrendous
waiting times
labour avoids talking about brexit
because it's decided rightly or wrongly
to distance itself from remainer tags
and large sections of both the bbc and
government supporting newspapers appear
to go into an automatic crouch position
whenever the brexit issue looms large
many broadcasters fear discussing the
obvious economic cause of major change
in this country in case they get labeled
pessimistic
anti-populist or worse still see above
unpatriotic
and yet every day that we sidestep these
issues with glaring emissions feels like
a conspiracy against the british people
we are pushing the public
further away
why should our viewers our listeners
come to us to interpret and explain
what's going on
when they can see our own reluctance to
do so
so that's why
i believe we have some catching up to do
journalism isn't a dry academic study or
a polished set of rules it is a
connection we share with our audience
when we're helping them to understand
things better
the behavior i describe here much of it
my own was not a solution it was a
coping strategy
so how do we move on from that
where are the solutions
well
firstly i suspect
it's about sunlight we need to show our
workings more
we need to be braver about explaining
the pressures under which we come
and our own responses to them
and in that spirit
i will admit
without getting too meta that as i stand
here as i'm speaking to you i'm
conscious of an internal self-editing
i'm still thinking
what the headlines of this speech will
be
will they make me look bad or dull or
preachy or reckless
will everyone fixate on one line about
corbyn or cummings
or trump
will it turn large parts of the press
against me
and will that stop me from going further
than i should if the goal ultimately is
to explain to the public how we do our
i'm telling you this
now so you know
i think we also need to find a glossary
a shorthand if you like we the frogs
have to give names to the populist
playbook tricks that we encounter the
infowars host alex jones
shortly to be 45 million dollars poorer
is not
a conspiracy theorist in the sense he
believes the rot he peddles
that doesn't appear to be the case
he peddles it to make money from
subscribers to whom he then sells
dietary supplements let's not
intellectualize and debate the merits of
this as free speech any more than we
would fake medicines this is just a
business model
when we hear donald trump or zach
goldsmith or nadine doris or marjorie
taylor greene talking about a witch hunt
or boris johnson going the way of deep
state chat our senses should be primed
this is often a precursor to the
rejection of legitimate checks and
balances
we should ask why they're so afraid of
scrutiny
we should be aware the parallel that is
not remotely parallel the fbi search on
trump's house at mar-a-lago this month
was reimagined by trump for his
supporters as equivalent to richard
nixon's burglary of the watergate office
building
it wasn't
it's a trope see false equivalence
just as we now understand when we hear
the phrase fake news we should think of
trump's own definition for it a
conscious attempt to discredit and
demean let's not turn ourselves inside
out wondering if it's true
so the more we recognize these tropes as
old slightly sadder malign friends the
better equipped we are to call them out
next perhaps the style of our reporting
can change too
i'm excited to see how the podcast we're
launching next week with global and
persefonica the news agents will allow
us room to move away from cellophane rap
formality to lift the curtain on why
things happen how we choose our stories
and how we book our guests we've got the
news agents here on the front row dino
lewis sopel soaps gabriel and there's
others back home who are watching but
we're keen to bring you what we're going
to do next and i hope that instead of
the cliched stagecraft of supporter x
versus supporter y
we might choose nuance as we did
occasionally on americast they're a
conversation sometimes would go like
this what do you think of politician a
that's us asking and the member of the
public would say
liar charlatan hypocrite and we'd say
you voted for him last time would you
again and the member of the public would
say
yes probably
because actually people are complicated
they're not cardboard cutouts an
exchange like that might tell us more
about say trump's appeal to the latino
gay floridian businessman or johnson's
appeal to the cheshire mother and
fitness instructor in a way that staunch
advocates cannot
the news agents podcast allows us the
chance to build loyalty with people who
like something with its edges on display
daily news now accounts for 10
of all podcast downloads crucially it's
attracting newer and younger audiences
so it is imperative for both them and
for us that we get this right
fourthly tweets the professor of
political communication caster freeze
asks would a news organization publish a
corporate press release in full without
offering context or asking questions
we do so with tweets
he believes we should hold social media
messages to the same standard even if
they come from say a head of government
tweets need the same level of scrutiny
in terms of whether they should even be
considered for publication
we are
at our most basic
the mediators between the actions of
those in power and the public
so fifthly finally
most excitingly the challenge for us i
think
is how we live up to that responsibility
in a way that is both fair
and robust
because either without the other
is useless
so let me finish
with an example that my colleague louis
goodall threw in the path of ideas as we
mold over the voyage
of our poor boiling frog
let's imagine he said provocatively
the supreme court in america has
overturned brown versus the board of
education
that 1954 landmark ruling that would
forever end racial segregation in public
schools let's imagine that's overturned
what would the media do then he asked
so i'm asking that now would we just
document it settled fact
will we call it out as racist
would we offer up both sides
leave people to decide if they like it
is it enough
in other words
to report things that might radically
change the very fabric of our
democracies and our societies
as if they were merely a weather update
leaving no discernible impact on the
lives of those we address
it is a big leap and i'm not by the way
suggesting anything of the sort is going
to happen in america
but i ask the question here
because it scares me because whilst we
don't have to be campaigners
but nor should we be complacent
complicit onlookers
our job is to make sense of what we're
seeing
and anticipate
the next move
it's the moment
in other words
that frog should be leaping out of the
boiling water and phoning all its
friends to warn them
but by then
we're so far along the path of passivity
we're cooked
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you